c'est un nouveau coup de gueule porté
par à mousse qui a agité la toile hier
c'est que ça dure aussi longtemps
un coup de gueule pour la soeur de son
meilleur ami qui a décidé de mettre fin
à ses jours alors qu'elle était
étudiante elle a été retrouvée pendue
dans son appartement jeunes étudiants et
j'ai l'impression que cette ce
gouvernement s'emballe littéralement les
couilles
il est vrai que ces derniers jours
beaucoup de genevois tout leur rêve
s'envoler et n'arrivent plus à voir
l'avenir à cause de cette pandémie avec
beaucoup de colère et d'émotions tram ou
s'en est pris directement au
gouvernement et au président de la
république qu'il juge responsables
président vous avez tué cette jeune
fille parce que le comedy dessus certes
mais on nomma général parle de ça
la vidéo de 10 minutes a été énormément
partagé pour beaucoup il est temps
d'agir
ramos et sur notre plateau ce soir pour
nous expliquer son coup de gueule
merci on va donc se faire c'est d'être
là on direct sur des pmp vous êtes le
témoin du jour à 20h25
et alors après le suicide de la soeur de
votre ami je vous ai vu c à vous et y
est restée plus il faut des buts très
très en colère hier hier soir c'était
partagé entre la peine d la colère et je
me rends compte que même après avoir
fait cette vidéo la colère elle elle
redescend pas parce que j'ai reçu
énormément de messages après la vidéo
d'étudiants de gens qui souffrent si
j'ai fait la vidéo c'est surtout parce
que mon ami me l'a demandé sinon je
l'aurais pas fait mais j'avais juste
besoin de dire au président qu'il faut
redescendre de son château doré et se
rendre compte que il ya beaucoup de gens
qui souffrent et que je suis pas sûr que
tous tes décisions tour été prises ont
été faites dans le bon timing
alors elle a décidé de l'être avant son
suicide là elle écrit quoi je pars
entrer dans le détail parce que je pense
que ça reste un petit peu dans
l'intimidation et donc mais c'est grosso
modo de danse et sur les détails mais
voilà c'est réellement la situation
actuelle la crise sanitaire qui l'a
poussé à commettre avec l âge n 21 ans
elle faisait quoi donc comme et des
études de médecine et ironie du sort
elle a craqué elle a craqué parce que
parce que déjà c'est une fille qui était
pétillante
[Musique]
c'était une jeune fille qui qui
respirait la joie de vivre qui était
pétillante qui était brillance à l'image
de sa famille elle avait perdu sa
grand-mère quelques quelques semaines
avant elle a décidé de ne s'en aller de
son propre choix
c'est triste mais c'est pas un cas isolé
comme l'a dit son grand frère parce que
c'est pourquoi vous avez fait la vidéo
et pourquoi son grand frère vous
demandez la faire c'est que vous avez
envie d'arrêter cette spirale autour des
étudiants autour des jeunes qui fait qu'
ils sont de moins en moins le moral
c'est ça je pense que ça a été un petit
peu une génération sacrifiée sont
beaucoup oublié dans cette crise c'est
vraiment très difficile pour eux moi
quand je vois que dans le pays de la
bouffe il ya des gens qui meurent de
faim des étudiants riz et que trente ans
plus tard après la création des
mythiques restos du coeur par coluche il
ya des étudiants qui mangent aux restos
du coeur et qui vivent grâce à ça moi
j'ai un peu honte donc il est grand
temps que tu as deux vis de l'autre pays
liberté égalité fraternité
on lui redonne au moins le premier
symbole alors comme vous l'avez dit de
nombreux jeunes sont dans la même
situation qu'elle aujourd'hui où elle
est elle s'en sortait pas non ben je
sentais pas parce que déjà là bas un
crédit étudiant parce que ses parents
l'aider comme il pouvait mais c'était
une famille très modeste et parce que
parce que elle avait un petit job parce
que c'est difficile parce que quand tu
vois que ton rêve qui est de devenir
médecin est ton rêve qui est de réussir
ta vie professionnellement s'écroule
c'est difficile de tenir le coup mais
j'ai bu alors on est on a vu votre vidéo
vous avez vu des extraits de sa vidéo
dans cette tragédie un coupable pour
vous c'est évidemment là qu vide mais au
delà c'est les décisions qui sont prises
par le gouvernement
pourquoi est-ce que vous tenez le
gouvernement responsable parce que quand
une équipe de foot et éclaté au sol
c'est son sélectionneur qu'on comprend
du doigt s'est pas laissée silence
d'incision vous dérange mais justement
ces décisions qui n'ont pas été prise à
temps et qui n'ont été n'était là c'est
une catastrophe salaires le pays n'a
actuellement faut arrêter de se leurrer
faire des grands discours
voilà des allocutions la foire était la
poudre de perlimpinpin
il est grand temps de remettre l'église
au milieu du village le pays va très mal
moi ce président là c'est le président
qui est venu en disant je vais enlever
lisf parce qu'on va essayer de faire en
sorte que les riches investissent désolé
les riches et sont partis faire une ba
café à dubaï
ça va donc il faut juste arrêter de
mentir faut essayer de se mettre à la
place du gouvernement certes mais
franchement j'ai pas le temps quand un
président dans un timing comme celui-là
il décide d'aller faire un concours
d'anecdotes avec de youtube heures que
j'aime beaucoup on s'entend très bien et
carlito j'ai eu au téléphone tout à
l'heure
d'ailleurs il vient de récolter 30 mille
euros pour une association très bien à
leur place je l'aurais fait aussi mais
je pense que lui il a poussé le vice un
petit peu trop loin alors ça c'était une
belle opération même pour pour les
gestes barrières pour le clip voilà pour
faire un post sur une route comme c'est
aussi pour voilà pour sensibiliser les
jeunes sensibiliser les jeunes se
pensaient que ces voix là il s'est
adressé et mac faye carlito mais c'est
vrai que ça fait une polémique cette
histoire aussi d'anecdotes hommes et ils
ont raison de le faire maquiller karito
et voilà j'ai eu au téléphone tout à
l'heure ils ont vraiment raison je
l'aurais fait à leur place c'est pas ça
le problème c'est que c'est sa démarche
à lui qui me gêne c'est que c'est un
coup de com c'est un coup de com qui est
mal venue alors redorer son blason ou
par rapport à la jeunesse qu'il a
totalement abandonné donc pour moi c'est
honteux qui va être content des saoud
une histoire et il ya des choses sur
lesquelles je suis
pas d'accord la responsabilisation
personnelle du président mais sur les
étudiants sur le fond je rejoins ce que
vous faites et je trouve que votre cri
d'alarmé
il a le mérite d'alerter il ya presque 2
millions d'étudiants en france
les étudiants de première année
notamment aujourd'hui moi j'en connais
beaucoup ils vivent un drame
ils sont complètement décroché
scolairement il ne mange plus ils ne
peuvent plus se soigner mais c est sur
ce que j'avais voilà que vous reveniez
sur ce que dira mot c'est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec lui ou pas sk qui
sont pas d'accord avec lui autour de la
table et qui trouve qui va peut-être
trop loin ou pas voilà alors c'est un
patin je me dis voilà je le manque ou
non pas sa pâte à bois voilà et voilà on
s'aime beaucoup donc vous pouvez quand
même lui dire les choses et bernard
montiel
moi je suis d'accord avec lui parce que
c'est un cri de douleur qui nous lance à
la figure assez violemment
maintenant d'incriminer le chef de
l'état c'est encore une autre histoire
c'est vrai que les étudiants c'est une
génération sacrifiée
cette année c'est la merde pour tout le
monde de toute façon il n'ya pas que les
étudiants c'est vrai que c'est honteux
les restos du coeur effectivement les
étudiants sont là tous les soirs à
quémander de la bouffe
si tout ça est extrêmement triste on vit
une pandémie c'est une situation
exceptionnelle dramatique dans le monde
entier
qu'est ce que tu veux faire qu'est ce
que tu veux faire c'est ce que ce que
vous trouvez qu'il faut mieux dans les
autres pays arabes ou pas ça c'est un
petit peu l'argument le carton jaune que
sortent les gens c'est à dire c'est pas
mieux à l'extérieur etc
mais je suis désolé c'est pas parce que
les autres sont des ânes que nous on
doit pas se considérer comme des rémois
servir que c'est compliqué pour c'est
compliqué certes mais je vois dans un
pays comme le nôtre quand on supprime
plus 3000 lits d'hôpital actuellement
dans une crise comme celle là c'est pas
bienvenus vous pensez pas qu'il ya des
personnes qui sont au chômage partiel
les personnes du btp qui n'auraient pas
été ravis de pouvoir construire un
hôpital pensais pas que ça c'est pas des
idées qui ont peint par rapport à tous
les gens qui sont au chômage
actuellement ne pensais pas qu'on en a
certains qui auraient aimé se réorienter
même si c'est temporaire pour aider les
services hospitaliers il ya près d'un an
qui veut travailler
faut arrêter de faire croire et je dis
pas que c'est vous parce que vous faites
très bien travaillé ici et je le
soutiens je te le dis assez c'est mon
pote à moi où est ce que je veux dire
c'est que y en a beaucoup qui prennent
les français pour des bras cassés mais
croyez moi ils ont été très disciplinés
et très patient c'est sûr avec
l'historique qu'on a un vrai show ni les
français ils ont été ils le sont encore
1 je le vois moi c'est moi je vous dis
moi je vois des trucs jeu quand je vois
les gens et je le dis j'en vois plein
air à 17h30 8h45 commence à stresser
maintenant c'est le couvre-feu je peux
pas dire que je trouve vraiment c'est
quand même admirable sous leurs robes et
ils le suivent à la lettre moi je suis
désolé je trouve que pour la plupart des
français ils sont extrêmement raffiné
mais je trouve que franchement ils font
et il en comprend pas on va se dire moi
je suis comme vous je comprends pas tout
ce qui se passe mais en tout cas on
essaie de suivre les indications
oui kelly alors j'ai vu la vidéo en
entier un moment donné où tu nous parles
tu nous parle de beaucoup de choses
parce qu'il n'a pas juste je suis ce
sujet là et à un moment donné tu nous
parles de mensonges de complotisme
peut-être ou consommables de nous pour
nous tous les soirs dès qu'on pourrait
être vulgaire donc j'aimerais ce que tu
ne dises en plateau pourquoi on nous
prend pour des cons
non moi je pense qu'on nous prend pour
des cons sur le timing la lenteur des
décisions et je dis pas que c'est fait
exprès chinois du goût le complotisme et
je pense que les gens qui me suivent au
quotidien le sahb chez le co vide
existant de nos problèmes et dans la
vidéo mais je suis désolé pardon oui est
ce que tu sais ce que je veux dire c'est
que ya un moment où des virus comme
celui-là il y en a plein on est quand
même la cinquième puissance mondiale
je pense qu'on a un an on était en effet
je veux dire on a largement eu le temps
de pouvoir apprendre à vivre en un an
avec le co vide et de pouvoir être dans
une société à peu près normale
aujourd'hui ce que vivent les jeunes
c'est inédit moi quand je vois les gens
ce qu'ils font dans la rue aujourd'hui
comment ils s'entretuent je me dis que
ça il se mettre des coups de couteau la
prochaine génération ça est très
compliqué pour les canaliser ramos juste
je te laisse si tu allais là une minute
pour t'adresser voilà comme tu le fais
sur des réseaux sociaux au gouvernement
ou voilà aux autorités ou aux gens qui
nous regardent que leur dirais quoi je
pense qu' il est grand temps de prendre
ses responsabilités il est grand temps
de faire quelque chose d' arrêter de
faire patienter les français avec un
climat anxiogène comme ça qui nous
tombent tous les uns contre les autres
je pense simplement qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ont des idées que aujourd'hui
les sans abri d'aujourd'hui c'était les
restaurateurs et des étudiants dire et
ça c'est à cause du coc vide mais c'est
aussi à cause des décisions qui ont été
prises et aujourd'hui faut se rendre à
l'évidence on va recommencer art confiné
c'est ce qui a été annoncé à dunkerque
est aujourd'hui partiellement dans
certaines villes mais il commence à
réouvrir donc c'est que niveau timing on
est un peu comme une très connus société
de train de faire on a toujours un train
de retard et les grand temps de prendre
vraiment le wagon correctement merci
ramous en tout cas justin
cloud azure et damman je vais dire un
truc à toi directement dans les yeux
parce que il ya quelques années il ya
deux ans quand on travaille ensemble sur
banshee et j'espère qu'il va revenir
n'ayant grand plaisir si c'est si c'est
une proposition accepte avec grand
plaisir ce que je veux dire c'est que à
cette époque là je suis rentré dans ta
loge arrêté que tous les deux caméras
éteintes et je t'ai dit cyril il ya une
colère qui grandit dans le pays
la série c'est difficile pour les gens
et je tiens à dire devant la caméra
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
fantasment tu as eu des paroles très
fortes
tu m'as dit ou au plateau sera toujours
bien pour ces gens avant la hype et la
clé la grande mode d'inviter les gilet
jaune est bien pour ça tu as mon respect
éternel atteint d'amendé mais je sais
qu'elle couilles que de coeur et je le
dis peu importe ce qu'ils mesureront
n'importe quoi et à personne n'y a aucun
lèche bottes ya juste quelqu'un qui crie
son grand frère battu à mort donc
j'étais fier de ce qu'il fait au
quotidien
bah tu sais que moi si je suis fier de
toi et je sais que tu es vrai je suis
énormément et je trouve ta énormément de
talent et tu sais que je vois là
j'espère tueur travaillera avec moi
bientôt avec grand plaisir formidable et
bien sûr le plateau est toujours ouvert
ici pour voilà tous les gens qui veulent
s'exprimer et merci ramous d'être venus
d'ex mais ce soir il